[APPLAUSE]
Good afternoon.
I'm Phillip Khoury.
I'm Associate Provost with
responsibility for the arts
here at MIT.
And I want to welcome you
to the public presentation
by Olafur Eliasson of
the 2014 Eugene McDermott
Award in the Arts at MIT.
We look forward to a
stimulating presentation
about the wide range of the
remarkable artist's work.
The title of his presentation is
intriguing, to say the least--
Holding Hands with the Sun.
Now before introducing
Olafur, let
me extend a special greeting
to Mrs. Margaret McDermott.
She's a dear friend--
[APPLAUSE]
She is a dear friend,
extraordinary benefactor.
A very special guest
who traveled all the way
from her home in Dallas
to be with us on this,
the 40th anniversary of
the Eugene McDermott Award.
I had the enormous privilege
of visiting with Margaret
in Dallas, just a few weeks ago
where she is the city's leading
patron of the arts.
Her hospitality, incidentally,
is second to none.
Accompanying Margaret
on this visit
is her daughter, Mary
Anne McDermott Cook,
who is with us right here.
Delighted you're here, Mary.
[APPLAUSE]
Among her many activities
in Dallas and beyond,
she is president of the
Eugene McDermott Foundation.
We're thrilled, really,
to have you, both of you,
returned here back to MIT.
You honor us by being here.
Let me say a few words
about the McDermott Award
and what the McDermott
family has done for MIT.
Established in 1974
by Margaret McDermott
to honor her late
husband Eugene,
co-founder of Texas
Instruments, the McDermott Award
recognizes individuals whose
artistic trajectory and body
of work indicate that they
will achieve the highest
distinction in their fields.
The award is considered an
investment in the recipient's
future creative
work, rather than
a prize for a particular project
or a lifetime of achievement.
A special feature of the
award is the campus residency,
and an important focus, one
that Mrs. McDermott herself
has encouraged.
That is the direct
interaction with students,
a goal that has been
realized in exemplary ways
in this residency.
Most of all, the McDermott
Award reflects MIT's commitment
to risk-taking, problem-solving,
and connecting creative minds
across disciplines.
I just want to add that the
McDermott family have been
major contributors to MIT's top
ranked public art collection,
and the McDermott
Scholarship Endowment Fund
has supported more
MIT undergraduates
than any such fund at MIT.
It really is a tribute to this
family and their support to us.
Now permit me to recount
just a few aspects
of Olafur Eliasson's work,
some of which, of course,
you just witnessed.
I believe you'll understand why
he's such an ideal recipient
of the McDermott Award.
His extraordinary body of
work encompasses a broad range
of creative practices spanning
art, science, and psychology.
He has made strikingly original
contributions to public art,
to architecture, and recently
to social entrepreneurship.
His installation,
The Weather Project,
which we just saw a bit of,
was visited by more than two
million people.
For this project, he installed
an immense artificial sun
in London's Tate
Modern, transforming
that cavernous turbine hall
with a theory of light and fog,
and producing a completely
unique, immersive environment.
Through such phenomenological
investigations of light, color,
atmosphere and water, he has
probed the nature of space
and of human perception.
Olafur Eliasson is
probably best known
in this country for
two exhibitions.
One is Take Your
Time, Olafur Eliasson.
It was a survey exhibition
organized in 2007
by the San Francisco
Museum of Art, which
traveled until 2010,
stopping in New York at MoMA
and at the Dallas Museum of Art.
The other is New
York City Waterfalls,
commissioned by the
Public Art Fund in 2008
with the support of
then-Mayor Michael Bloomberg.
It's a series of four
man-made waterfalls
in the East River in New York.
Most recently, our
McDermott honoree
collaborated with
engineer Frederick Ottesen
who is with us this evening,
to develop Little Sun, which
you saw in the video.
A portable solar powered LED
lamp for the 1.6 billion people
worldwide without
access to electricity,
which he calls a work of
art that works in life.
You will understand why Olafur
Eliasson's work resonates
with the creative values
of the MIT community.
We particularly admire the wide
ranging and ambitious nature
of his creative
practice, which spans
multiple domains without regard
for disciplinary boundaries.
We admire the collaborative
enterprise that
drives his creative output.
We admire his relentless
experimentation
with light, space,
movement, and the nature
of human perception,
which compels
audiences to engage
with their environment
and with one another.
And we admire his confidence
that art makes a difference
in this world of ours.
We look forward now to hearing
from Olafur Eliasson, our 2014
McDermott Award recipient.
Olafur, please come
up, and a round
of applause for his
remarkable arts.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
It's a long intro,
hard to follow.
A lot has been said already.
Thank you, Margaret,
for having me.
You look so great today.
It's very exciting to be here.
I have, in fact,
been here already
for what's now the second day.
And this is my fourth lecture,
and so I'm sort of warmed up.
And it's been a big
experience to enjoy
the hospitality of MIT.
Sort of hopping through the
departments and seeing all the
incredible, the massive
research going on,
and the degree of criticality
and self criticality.
So that, of course,
is very inspiring.
Yeah, I've had a very, now I
have so much stuff in my head,
so I hope I can, to
some extent, at least,
talk a little bit
about the works
that I brought on my computer.
Because I have a lot
of new ideas now.
But let me start by talking a
little bit about the project
that was briefly mentioned.
It is 10 years old,
as of this winter.
And it was a project
which, to me, meant
a sort of a strong
increase in the confidence
of the potential of what
creativity can actually do.
And it also brought
me to this idea
that, well, maybe it's
to some extent about art,
but maybe it's
really about people.
And I'm confident that
the systems in which
artwork, the museums
and galleries
and so on and so forth.
But also the wider systems,
the general confidence
in creativity in
art and culture,
in the greater society.
I'm sure that art has
something to offer which
is a kind of a model of
how we respect each other,
how we share things, how
we discuss with each other.
Art has something there, which
I think is highly valuable.
So I've become increasingly
involved with working
against the marginalization
of art and culture
in political systems,
in the sort of society
systems, the idea of what
is civic society, how
it is structured and so on.
The reason why this project
here at the Tate Modern
was important for me was
that it for me showed
a space in which people came
in, the turbine hall in London,
it's an old power station,
the south side of the Thames.
And the project opened,
and it was first
shown at the weather
forecast in the news.
And as we know,
Brits in England,
everybody loves the-- oh,
well like here today--
everybody loves the weather.
And the weather is interesting
because besides being
the nature, or the bit of
nature we have in cities--
you know, so it rains,
this is like the nature
entering culture, if you want--
but the weather
is sort of a space
where we can actually have
a different experience
of the weather.
Oh, I really hate when it
rains, and the person next to me
says, oh, I really
love when it rains,
and I still like
that other person.
I say, oh, we can be together.
So interestingly, a
museum, or a platform
on which one can have
art, is, to some extent,
a success with regards
to facilitating
this ability to disagreeing
and sharing at the same time.
So you can be singular--
this is my view on the world.
And you can at the
same time be plural.
This is, I need to
share the world,
disregarding that I disagree.
And as we look at the
greater society, we of course
can see a lot of, how shall I
say, polarization, exclusion.
Or if you disagree,
you're not welcome.
If you're different,
If you're not kind of
synchronizing with me,
I'm actually not going
to work with you.
So in this case, and I think
there is something about art
here, it was a space where
there was a highly singular,
or highly personal experience.
People, they looked,
and they sort of
started behaving
differently than they
do in museums normally.
As you can see, they
laid down on the floor.
They stayed longer.
They kind of brought in their
picnics, picnics on the floor.
And they sort of spent
time and used the museum
in different ways.
I would say it also
became a public space.
It was almost like the city
took a part of the museum
to its heart.
The idea of public
being something
where you can have
both shared experiences
and individual experiences
became possible.
I like this idea of
being singular and plural
at the same time.
I think there's something
very Democratic about it.
Something about sharing
values and also respecting
the individual needs.
See, this is a small film.
Let me see if I can turn it on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So people are, as you can
tell, laying on the floor.
The distance to the ceiling
is roughly 30 meters.
Of course, looking up to the
ceiling 30 meters is something,
but you're sort of looking
down again with 30 meters down
again.
So that means you're looking
60 meters and finding yourself
at a distance of 60
meters is exciting,
because you cannot help
seeing yourself in the context
of the space.
So you're not just
looking for yourself.
You are, in fact, also
seeing yourself in the,
let's say, in the greater
system of this space.
It's hard to focus and talk and
listen to me at the same time.
I could say a lot
about this project,
because also, I think
it's important to see
that looking at a work
of art almost as a,
I wouldn't say a machine,
but as a phenomena creator--
[END PLAYBACK]
--in which the performance
of the audience
of the user, or the
spectator, becomes
the vehicle for that work is
an interesting idea, I think.
I worked always, like, let's
see if we can hand over
a great degree of the
responsibility of making
the artwork to the people
who actually use it.
Use is sort of pragmatic and,
it's largely demystifying.
But use in the sense
that you make an effort,
you come into the
museum, and you engage.
You might immerse yourself.
You engage in terms of,
you go look for something.
When you look at
a work of art, you
start a journey in which
your effort is requested.
So it's not like consuming.
It's not like sitting in
a Hollywood sort of movie
and just kind of all taking it
all in, doing nothing, right?
You have to work a little bit.
You have to kind of give
a little bit of yourself.
If the artwork is
successful, I think
that it actually
succeeds in, how
should I say, verbalizing
something, or bringing language
to something which
you already feel.
You kind of have it in
yourself, but you haven't quite
verbalized it
yourself yet, right?
So you go and you
look for something,
and what you're looking
at is actually yourself.
And of course this can then be
debated and so on and so forth.
But generally speaking,
a great work of art
somehow brings to
language something
that you already know,
but you haven't quite
figured out how to say it.
So it's very interesting.
It's almost like
it reflects you.
So in that sense, it's a little
bit, I wouldn't say therapy,
but I just don't--
it's a little bit, go
and you make an effort.
And sometimes the effort
to understand something
is more important than
the understanding itself.
The effort, or the process,
or the time it takes for you
to kind of get involved--
and this is why this is such
an exciting little film--
the time it takes for
you to get involved
is as valuable as
the time for you
to kind of say, OK, now I
got it and I can go home.
See, there is not so many spaces
in the world that facilitates
that type of activity.
We have academia, we have great
academic sort of methodology.
And we have places
like MIT where
people exercise the
questions and the critique
of the questions as an integral
part of the question, right?
And, of course,
structural thinking,
structuralism and
postmodern thinking,
brought a lot of new tools
to the toolbox in which I
was educated-- the
times, the early '90s
and so on and so forth.
This is one of my
very first pieces.
It's a rainbow at-- in
the lack of a better
photo-- it's just drizzling
water and a little spotlight.
And as we know, a rainbow
takes a little more
than the spotlight and
the drizzling water takes.
It also needs the eye.
So you have the eye, this one.
It's funny, the eye actually,
it's like a little machine.
Right?
You can even see the eye--
do you know this experiment?
Probably somebody from MIT
came up with that experiment.
If you press the
eyeball, you can sort of
see how the image-- so there's
a little sort of spherical thing
in your head.
Anyway, the eye, drop, light.
That makes a rainbow.
So if I stand here,
I see one rainbow.
But my friend over here,
right, sees another rainbow.
So we can kind of agree,
OK, this is a rainbow.
But it's not the same rainbow.
It's two different rainbows.
And this is-- so,
so, so, so removing
the traditional object,
this is '93, making space
for the subject, or the
spectator, in this case.
Suggesting that the producing
the eye component is
a part of the artwork
was almost suggesting,
well, maybe the artist,
maybe the biographical sort
of material, is less important.
Maybe the biographical
material of the spectator,
the working spectator,
the producing spectator,
the co-author is
the protagonist.
This became the beginning of
investigating public space,
different spaces, architecture.
And this is a project.
This is in Sweden.
This is the
parliament in Sweden.
The parliament sort
of on the island.
This is called Strom.
It's a lovely, very
clean water, Strom.
The Swedes, they love their
clean water coming straight
up going into the ocean.
With a little bit of
non-toxic dye normally used
for tracking ocean currents, you
could, sort of with an instant,
you can kind of dye
a whole river green.
And a number of artists has
been played with these things.
And what I think is interesting
here is that this city as such
is, of course, when we think
about it, something organic.
It's the life between
buildings that makes up a city.
What sometimes happened
is that the city
is so self obsessed
with its own image
that it kind of leans towards
something more static.
We see a lot of
cities in Europe that
are, to some extent, at
least, turning into museums.
This is a debate within
urbanistic planning,
and to what extent
those cities actually
represent the values of the
societies in which they are.
Or are they becoming, so let's
say, monuments of certain times
where other values was guiding?
So the idea of sort
of recalibrating
the depth of the space with
regards to its hospitality.
I thought I could just
toss a little bit of color
into a river like
that, and kind of with,
almost like a shock effect,
suggest, well, this space
is, in fact, organic.
It moves, it passes by,
time is very important.
If you have time, you
also have activity.
If you have activity, there's
more space for people.
So in the great tradition of
very typically Scandinavian
investigative methodology of
how to generate public space.
This was, I think, a project
that I did again and again,
and with some success.
Next day, the police in
Sweden wrote in the paper
that a lot of people have
called into the police
and asked why on
earth, et cetera.
And the police have
calmed down people
saying that the
parliament actually had
a leak in the heating system.
[LAUGHTER]
This is the Swedish way
of keeping people calm.
[LAUGHTER]
But so the idea of making things
explicit at the Green River.
Making it explicit is
also having confidence
in the physicality of it.
Instead of looking at a picture,
actually engaging in the,
let's say, the
water and the things
that are hard to understand.
So it's just time.
Passing of time.
It's like, a little
bit abstract.
One of the great questions
today is like, everybody
knows what a glacier is.
Of course, some people even
have been on a glacier.
But everybody also knows, so
we have the climate crisis,
and we have the general
question about how
to understand what ice is,
and what the climate is,
and what the
ephemeral sort of is.
The changing of climate.
I'm a part of a generation
where when I was a child,
the climate was natural.
So it was considered,
OK, here I'm in culture,
and over there is nature.
This is interesting.
And I was, you know,
when I grow up,
I hiked a lot with my father.
And so I went a lot to
a glaciers and so on.
But as I grew older,
I realized, well,
the climate is not natural.
The climate is,
in fact, cultural.
It is, to some extent, an
increasingly accepted man-made.
Or woman-made.
And the thing here is,
I think the thing is,
the challenge lies
with, how do we make
things explicit from
theoretical knowledge
to physical knowledge?
Because that's an
old story within art.
And if you have an
idea here, oh, I
have an idea for a work of art.
It's still not a work of
art until I've done it.
The journey between thinking
and doing, as we know,
can be very wide.
And there's a lot
of steps in there
where you are sort of working
as a mechanical engineer,
if you want.
The same thing, right?
Thinking, doing.
And the steps, I think,
are very important.
And when I've been here at
MIT, sort of on a side note,
it is all about bringing
thinking and doing together.
Bridging that gap.
So in this case, I thought,
well, people in Berlin
here can't go to Iceland.
So I'll just bring
the glacier to Berlin.
So I froze down a
space, minus 10 degrees.
And then the glacial
blocks of the Vatnajokull,
they drops off the glacier as
it sort of falls into the ocean.
And I could pick it up
with a tractor on the beach
and just ship it in a frozen
fish container to Berlin.
Very easy, actually.
And then I showed them, as you
can tell, it's so beautiful,
the ice itself.
And what is maybe
more important is
that you can actually touch it.
And it's incredible.
And you touch it, you
go, oh, it's really cold.
It's so funny.
And there is
something here which
is very sensitive, because
it's about bringing-- oh, we
knew it was cold.
No surprise.
But yet, when you touch
it, it is different
than from what you knew.
So this is very important.
The kind of idea of bringing
knowledge and action together,
simply by touching.
So the title here, holding
hands with his son,
you can see where this is going.
So let me just show this.
Now I have to [INAUDIBLE].
So this is, it's going
to be a little loud.
Or maybe not.
Let me just say something
before I start it,
because I could tell before
you didn't listen when I was
[INAUDIBLE].
So basically, ice floor.
Very big ice floor,
totally known.
This is in Sao Paolo.
It's at the Sao Paolo
biennial quite a while ago.
So, interestingly, everybody,
like everybody is, as I said,
know about ice.
That's very easy.
From a distance, already.
Oh, it's ice.
And then you sort
of, oh, interesting.
Then you start running.
So very disruptive
to the exhibition.
Again, so people running
through the exhibition.
And they're kind of
being loud, and so on.
And have a look at this.
And just see how I get it going.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [WHOOPING, CHEERING, LAUGHING]
So it's very destabilizing.
And sorting out
your motoric skills,
disregarding that you know
very well what ice is.
So this is the
opening in Sao Paolo.
And I was sort of wondering
what was going to happen.
And people are reconsidering
the rules [INAUDIBLE]..
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It was just too much.
It sort of didn't fit the kind
of behavior construct of an art
institution.
I don't know if you can see.
The ice continues
on the outside.
You can see in the
back of [INAUDIBLE],,
there's a bit of ice outside.
If you couldn't
pay, or didn't want
to pay [INAUDIBLE] to
go in, you could also
have a little skate
on the outside.
And that glass boundary
was interesting,
because we know that glass is
a big social boundary and so
on and so forth.
This is a Fantastic
Niemeyer building.
So this idea of
social boundaries.
So I don't mean
to, by all means,
there's not so much
ice in Sao Paolo.
And I don't mean, you know,
there's so much other stuff,
so it's not really about that.
But listen, the thing is the
discrepancy between knowledge
and physical knowledge
became very clear here.
Because some people actually
sat down on the ice said,
oh, it's nice and cool
here in this hot space.
And the nice thing was they
said, oh, my god, the ice
is melting when you sit on it.
But so they knew perfectly
well what it was.
[INAUDIBLE] being.
This is Sylvie Fleury.
Do you know her?
So my home, my private
home video here.
This is the curator being
a little bit concerned.
[LAUGHTER]
That was Adriano Pedrosa.
But let me see if I can--
[END PLAYBACK]
So these sorts of interventions
investigating the boundaries
of where do our, how far does
our tolerance, our hospitality,
our sense of space
go with regards to,
can we actually exercise the
idea of diversity we have?
Because we have such great
thoughts about how resourceful
we are with regards
to hospitality.
So we think, of course,
you could do anything
if you want in this museum.
We can have any type
of exhibition you want,
as long as it's not noisy, of
course, and so on and so forth.
So, again, even our
values, the values
we carry with us through
society, sometimes we think,
oh if somebody falls
over on a bike, of course
I would go over and
help the person get up.
But then you're on the street
and somebody falls over
on a bike and we go, oh, my
god, this person is drunk.
Or can I help, or am I
going to get into-- so all
these sort of
boundaries between what
and how do you act
in public space.
Right?
It's very complex.
And of course, we would
want a public space
that actually facilitates
the trust in this way.
But the truth is, that's
not always the case.
What type of space, what
type of architecture,
what type of pavement
actually facilitates
the values that we
think we have, but we
don't know actually how
to bring into doing?
This is a project,
this is Johannesberg.
It's also in the '90s.
I emptied out a small
rainwater reservoir
to kind of create the little
river that I called Erosion.
Wasn't an accident.
I was invited for a biennial,
had a nice little photo
piece about Scandinavia.
And I was walking around in
downtown derelict Johannesburg
at the time, '96,
I think it was.
Okwui Enwezor was the curator.
And I said, oh my god,
this is so typical.
Here I am, all the way
from Berlin at the time,
in Johannesburg.
My god, I have to do
something different than just
showing a photo.
Obviously a photo of Iceland,
you know, by all means.
So I said, oh, look at this
incredible rainwater reservoir.
Why don't I rent a
little diesel pump
and empty it out on the street
and see if I can make a river?
And of course, the
curator, I didn't ask him
because, of course,
because it was sort of,
it was interesting times.
So '96 Johannesburg, downtown
derelict squatter buildings.
You know, the Anglo American--
no, the Anglo-Saxon bank,
the Diamond Stock Exchange,
the diamond building.
And very complex,
very complex area.
And I thought the idea
of erosion, time, river--
like a poem.
Like a little river that
just comes and goes,
was very beautiful.
It's rainwater, so
it wasn't really,
it rains enough for
collecting the water
and using it for
public irrigation.
And this is the river.
I can talk more about it.
As you can tell, it ran
roughly a mile and a half
through sort of organized
and unorganized areas,
and it ended up in the sewer.
This is in Los Angeles.
Lots of sun, morning, sort
of midday, late afternoon.
And if you walk in,
you can actually
see that the light is moving.
It's very beautiful,
very good for LA.
You sort of stand there.
You go like, mm-hmm.
Is this art?
And then you go,
and then you go--
then it's like interesting.
There's nothing there.
And suddenly, your own presence
becomes quite explicit.
And you're so-- so,
so it's interesting.
Before, the light was over
there, and now it's here.
Suddenly there's that
kind of cosmic connection.
I won't overdo that,
but it's interesting,
because it actually
does change a lot.
Have you been on
the street watching
how the pull of the
shadow of a streetlamp,
it actually moves,
like, very fast.
And that is the speed with
which the planet travels
through space around the sun.
Obviously, as we
have come to learn,
the sun actually doesn't move.
It's the Earth that goes around.
So what you can see is,
in fact, you're traveling.
And it's time travel.
So to some extent,
it's the time it takes.
So there's a lot
of stuff in here.
And I think what
we are, I guess,
to some extent with
regards to being abstract,
making things explicit
also has to do with,
do we actually succeed
to see the planet?
Or sort of the idea of
the planet as one thing?
How do we identify with
the planet as one object?
So I've been very interested
in these sort of questions
from cosmology or
deep space cosmology.
How do you understand the planet
in the context of the universe?
Now this gets a little
abstract, but the point here
is I think one of the
greater challenges
with regards to, for
instance, the climate crisis,
we spoke about that.
The climate crisis
is that it does
require that you kind of think
of the planet as an object.
Sort of does, you do
need to sort of think
of everything at the same
time, which is very difficult.
Because it's so difficult
enough to even understand
America has one
sort of ecosystem,
to see the whole thing.
And this idea of
interdependence,
collectivity, the global
sort of idea of sharing,
of sharing responsibility,
how does responsibility feel?
It's very difficult. So
in that, and of course,
that's a far stretch
to say a spot of light
on the floor and
then responsibility.
It's a bit-- but still, I
think, if one can actually
think of yourself in the
context of something planetary,
if you want, think of Kepler.
The work he did.
And that was so
groundbreaking in a way.
Not that this is quite
on the scale of Kepler.
But I would like to I would
like to toss this work of art
into kind of trajectory
or the orbit of Kepler,
Kepler-ish kind of thinking.
Same question.
Glacier, glacier melting, river
running, aerial photography.
And somewhere in the middle,
roughly here three rows up,
there's a dam being
built. This is a water--
what you can-- hydroelectric
power dam being
built in Iceland.
So this means the lower--
no, the upper half--
I mean, everything on the
left side and up from that dam
is now underwater.
It's almost a mile deep on
the deepest part, 800 meters.
That's not quite a mile.
But it's a very
deep at the deep.
And then everything else on
the right side is still there.
So this is a little documentary
of a space that was,
which is now underwater.
And of course, the whole
question of dam [INAUDIBLE]
electricity, the company from
America built who's running
this to melt aluminum,
there's a very--
lot of debates.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a complex photo
documenting something.
A black river on a
snowy white landscape.
So almost like a Japanese
calligraphic poem.
Chinese, if you want.
So, I have a handful
of works like this.
I thought I will just
walk you through them.
There's not a lot left.
And then we have roughly half
an hour for some questions.
You see?
Do you see?
I mean, I always
wonder whether I
should talk long for
a few works, or less
for a lot of work.
So now I'm kind of in between.
I hope it's OK.
I hope it's OK for you.
This is the waterfalls
project that I
was lucky to do in New York
together with the mayor's
office.
A lot of people came together
and supported this project.
One of the main supporters,
Aggie, who is here tonight.
It's great to see you, Aggie.
The waterfalls, I
thought, for me, it
was about claiming space.
Taking space, simply.
I know from Iceland, when
I'm in front of a landscape,
and I look at the
landscape, and I always
get so excited because
there's nothing
in the landscape that
kind of indicates
the size of the
scale, the depth.
And you look at it,
there's no trees.
You almost cannot
even see the wind,
because there's
no grass blowing.
There's no-- the
things that normally
indicate depth, distance,
height, are gone.
It's like being on the moon.
And you go, like, hmm?
One way of making
dimensions is by walking.
And so I start walking.
And the two mountains
in front of me, one
comes closer very fast, and
one stays on the horizon.
That means, oh,
the two mountains
that I thought was roughly
the same size, actually,
this one is a small
mountain close by,
and the other one is a
big mountain far away.
So by walking, I can
create a sense of scale,
not just out there in the
landscape, but also in my body.
If I don't walk, and I stop and
I look around, it's hard for me
to understand, again, the scale.
But then there's a waterfall.
I look at the waterfall and
I go and I see the water.
It falls very slowly.
And I say, oh, it's
a high waterfall.
Because water falls roughly
with the same speed.
And suddenly I realized
the waterfall is also
a sort of temporal indicator.
It gives space
not just the time,
but it also gives you the depth.
I can, by looking
at the waterfall,
see how long time it
takes me to walk there.
I can measure the
distance from here
to the waterfall and the
height simply by looking at it.
It's very interesting.
I was sitting in
the Simien mountains
in the northern end of
Ethiopia, sort of looking
into the south of Sudan.
And the amazing landscape
is on the roof of Africa,
it's also called the
Simien mountains.
And you can have your legs
off the cliff like this,
and there's a drop of
a mile, approximately.
A kilometer, [INAUDIBLE].
So, amazing winds, the birds
sort of coming up from--
and you just sit there
and you just see the sun,
and it's totally amazing.
And I go, like, wow, look.
I wonder how far away these
small mountains down there is.
And this has all been, I think
it's like in 3,000 meters
height.
What is that, 10,000 feet?
So and then I go and then I
look down the rim, and I see,
oh, there's a
waterfall over there,
and then the water
falls so slow.
And I go, (GASPS)
it's really deep.
And I take my legs in.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, so it's
very interesting
what water can do to space.
So now, look at public space.
Look at American public
space, the history
of public space, John
Dewey, the work that
has been made into making space
the place in which we meet
and share and exchange.
And also, a public space
has a rich history.
There's different versions.
There's an East Coast,
West Coast, different ideas
in New York and LA.
So lots of material rights.
Then there's Europe,
the idea of Europe.
Southern Europe,
Northern Europe is
in sort of the
Italian public space,
the kind of meeting
up type of space,
and the Northern European.
And so something
which I find very
interesting as a space
which is, to a great extent,
there to facilitate
and reflect the values
that we have in our society.
And to the extent that this
is a success, we can debate.
Because of course,
what happens is
that public space is, to
a great extent privatized.
It is full of intentionality,
structures, power structures,
political structures,
and so on where we
think of it as being public--
meaning free-- but it
is, in fact, not free.
What do we do to claim it back?
So the waterfalls, for
me, was about suggesting
ephemeral, temporal, sort
of experiential materials.
Like qualities indicating that
this space actually has depth,
especially the sort of
skyline in New York.
It's the greatest skyline, but
you also kind of look at it
and say, oh, it's
exactly like a postcard.
So it's a little bit like
what I said about Stockholm
in the beginning.
We have to make sure that a
space allows for the people
to be in it.
Sometimes a space can be so self
obsessed with its own rendering
that it is only
happy when rendered.
We need to allow space to
have enough space for people
to meet.
And you need a
little space to meet.
Like, 100 meter,
50 meter, 20 meter.
Then at 50 meter, you can
say, oh, it's a man or woman.
20 meter, you can see
whether they're smiling.
10 meter you can can tell,
oh, better I should move out,
I should go to the person.
That space is important.
This is the space in which
we build trust in each other.
If you don't have that
space, and if there's always
kind of a store
reaching out hey, kid,
we want your attention.
If we don't have enough space
for us to sort of also see,
[SIGHS] how do I feel?
Do I feel OK?
Does this space
actually support my idea
of going over to the
person who fell on the bike
and helping the person?
Or does the space say,
oh, don't-- just get,
just put on your Walkman
and just go, just go on.
So very interesting,
these things.
So the resources,
besides me being obsessed
about Iceland and waterfalls
and all of that thing,
I think this is--
so for me, it was about that,
and asking these questions.
This is in Denmark.
A museum, art museum.
And I proposed them to
put a rainbow on the roof,
like a permanent rainbow.
So that idea is still around.
Do you remember?
And here you have a rainbow.
If you stand in one place
and just do nothing,
nothing changes.
You stand in the red area,
everything's just red.
Which is not so bad, also.
But if you walk--
which is also, if you work--
then things happens.
If you walk around,
the color changes.
This means that
the walking itself
is what creates here
the work of art.
What people do is that
they come up here.
It's a lovely walk,
because you kind of go
through all the colors.
And it's, as you can tell,
it's really a very basic idea.
And a lot of things happens
because the museum, of course,
got very excited because a lot
of people who normally did not
come to the museum suddenly
started going to the museum
saying, wow, this is art.
It is also about
looking at the world.
It is about the perspective
of looking, right?
So we talk about [INAUDIBLE].
And suddenly the
museum downstairs,
the distance between
the two paintings
became very interesting.
You look at a painting,
a great Munch painting,
they have amazing
Munch paintings.
But maybe the distance from
one Munch painting to the next
is also interesting.
The time it takes
for you to digest
the narrative you just took in
and how that produces the next.
So the sequence of the
temporal aspects of a museum
is, of course, where
the potential lays.
It's not like I looked
at a Munch painting
and then I'm off.
And then, boom, again I
look at a Munch painting.
The success of a
museum is, of course,
the kind of temporal
narrative that people
take with them home.
We don't remember moments.
We remember pieces of time.
The concert house.
So you can say I got more
involved with architecture.
Crystalline structures,
mathematical systems.
This is a quasi crystalline
pentagonal principle
brought into a kind of all
space filling principle.
All space filling is
when you stack stuff
without any cracks between them.
So some time ago, I was
lucky to have an engineer
sort of think about who comes
out of visionary mathematics.
In my studio, I occupied
him for a while,
and he was obsessed
with all space filling
mathematical principles.
Stackable.
Everything was stackable.
This, as you can see,
is a stackable facade.
But crystalline and acrylic
glass and heat and [INAUDIBLE]..
Also a few questions of
climate and insulation
and technical solutions.
What is maybe most interesting
is what you see here.
Because if you're into
sort of facade structures
and you know a big steel
facade like that, then
you would know,
well, normally, there
would be a column holding it.
But as you can tell, it
just stands all by itself.
This means it's a self
carrying structure,
and so there is a bit of
engineering-- a bit of science,
if you want-- into making this
actually aesthetically active.
So that's a field that I've
been quite interested in.
So it's not an existing building
on which I apply a work of art
as kind of decorating, painting
on something already there.
It is a part of the
building structure.
So when the architect
asked me to get
involved because they needed
to win the competition,
I said, OK.
But I want to do something that
actually holds up the building.
I don't want to do something
that decorates the building.
If I'm not a part
of the building,
I won't be a part of the team.
Which of course,
was not a problem.
This is the model, my models.
This is, I've been looking
a lot into mathematical
and natural scientific systems
of space depiction and spatial
processes and so on.
I won't go into
that too much here.
The evolution of building.
This is actually, this
is quite a while ago
when the wall in
Berlin came down,
a few years did pass by before
the walls of Albania came down.
I was very interested in
Albania when it came down,
because Albania was so
close, and the city of Tirana
was just in the
center of Europe,
but it had not been accessible
as we all know and so on.
So quite early on after
Albania becoming open,
there was a number of
architectural competitions
in which I was involved.
And the mayor, Edi
Rama of Tirana,
invited me to be on a
sort of advisory board
for city planning.
And I was, not so long after
I was not involved anymore.
But the point here is that I
started looking into, well,
how do we hand over the
ownership of the space
to the people who were
deprived from thinking
that they could produce space?
And one of the process
was to let's make
a city plan out of LEGO bricks.
And I called Kjeld Kirk,
the owner of LEGO, said,
we need some LEGO
bricks in Tirana.
And he was very interested,
because the people had never
played with LEGO.
That's very interesting.
It's almost impossible.
And now there's,
like, no one left.
But so I said, let's
put in a big sort
of a table, the same
size as the kind of,
sort of roughly
depicting the city.
And then let's allow people
to go, and then build.
So a few things interesting.
People started territorially
thinking about, well,
should I be, or should it
be next to this person?
And the kind of policemen from
the city, the kids selling
cigarettes out of this
kind of [INAUDIBLE],,
they were standing
next to each other.
At some point, the gun
from the policeman's,
like, on the table, and
the cigarettes of the kid
was on this table.
It was very interesting.
And not that it was like kind
of a revolution or anything,
but there was this kind of
coming together on a project.
Details, a lot of the
buildings had the LEGO brick
the other way around.
Like with the sort of
round things going down.
Because nobody had
actually necessarily built.
And if you can see, they didn't
press them very well together.
Right?
So we grew up-- and
I don't mean this,
it's not like we and them.
But by all means, we--
it's just so interesting
that the kind of knowledge
that we have in our hands
pressing a LEGO brick together,
and so on.
So the LEGO owner, he
was actually there,
standing there, looking.
And he was so surprised they
wouldn't press it together.
He's an engineer.
So he said, why?
I wonder why people don't--
why?
And it was so interesting
seeing him looking at that.
And so, lots of lovely details.
But really, also about, what
does it mean to share a space?
What does it mean--
and, of course,
some people immediately
build a big wall
and a fence around them.
But some people started making
bridges and breaking down
the walls.
Oh, I have to do like this.
You sort of saw that
in the introduction.
I won't drag you
through that again.
But-- oh, now it's
going backwards.
I wonder if I--
you saw it before.
Point is, so sometimes,
in my studio,
I do these spatial experiments.
Some of them requires dancers
to bring the body back
into my work.
Then I record it and film
and make a little work up out
of it.
But the interesting
part is really the idea,
if you can walk very
slowly, and then you
have the kind of slow
motion trainer to come.
And then we practice
in the studio.
Not that I need people to
be slow, but interestingly,
everything else gets
proportionally fast.
So I tried this.
Oh.
I wonder whether I have a
slide where I'm walking?
No, I don't.
OK.
So anyway-- is it there?
Is it coming?
If I press here?
Is it after?
Later?
OK, anyway.
So it's coming up.
It's very difficult
to investigate time.
Obviously, time plays
a role in my works.
Oh, this is actually
a little film.
But the one I think you saw,
also, in the introduction.
But time being kind of a
coproducer of the works--
I'll just go on, I'm sorry.
Time being a coproducer
of the work is, I think,
very difficult,
but very important.
Because time is so
intangible, it's
difficult to control
and make explicit.
It does take time
to build confidence.
It does take time to
build self-confidence.
It takes time to experience.
So this means we do in the
studio where I occupy around
90 people, we do make
some effort in exercising,
how does the passing or the
flowing of time actually feel?
I should ask you, Margaret.
By all means.
It's just so important
that we don't
forget how the experience
builds the moment
and turns into memories.
So I work a lot with
this thing, and I
make an effort to
bring some communal,
let's say, projects
into the studio where we
invite people to come and eat.
We have a few lovely
chefs cooking every day.
And the 90 people is,
this is the moment where
the three teams in the studio,
the architectural teams,
the craftsmen who
works with their hands
and the archive, the
research and archive people,
they all meet.
And they exchange, you know,
formalities and informalities.
And often we have
friends like, you
can just see this is Rirkrit
down here in the corner,
grabbing, sneaking
in and having a bite.
The studio has-- if you
don't mind me walking down
the path of the studio a
little bit-- the studio has
on the top floor, that's
the red building there
on the left side,
it's the studio.
On the upper floor,
it has a school.
It had a school which
closed two weeks ago, where
I, for five years, under
the funding of the Science
Ministry in Berlin, were looking
into education and methodology
in art education.
I know Molly and a few friends
from here has also been there.
And we really tried to
build a system which
was driven by non-curriculum
education, where we took
for granted something
very important--
that the students were already
creative by the time they made
it into the school.
So I didn't have to
teach them to make art.
I was there to help them to
bring thinking into doing.
And also having confidence
with abstraction.
Something that is less
tangible, not quantifiable.
The success could
be in the temporal
and not in the sort of
solidification of the idea.
And the school brought about
it a lot of experiments.
So one experiment,
as you can see,
this is a flag,
kind of flagpole.
But the flag itself
is a piece of metal.
When the wind blowed, it was
like, it was like thunder.
It was a lovely student project.
So it's like the
thundering flag.
We took that down
to Addis Ababa where
I spent two months
with the studio also
teaching and collaborating
with the Addis Ababa University
and the department there.
And the thundering
flag of course,
meant something very
different in Ethiopia
than it does in Berlin.
Not too different, though.
Another flag.
So all the students, it sounds
like they only do flags,
but this is like a giant
flag that you sort of walk
through the city.
Or the idea of taking
away the eyes, sort
of getting a sense of space.
And student experiments
where physicality,
the doing component, was
maybe more in focus than the--
I wouldn't say
we're not thinking.
But thinking alone, for sure,
won't make you an artist.
Walking through the city
using a reflected image.
It's actually very difficult,
but an interesting exercise.
Because you have to kind
of work a little bit
on the construction
of how you see.
And suddenly, you
can make new rules.
Motoric, you know, frictions.
So taking away
the basic motoric,
just making the cutlery
like a meter long.
It's very difficult to--
see.
Where you kind of--
also spatial.
The famous studio
lioning experiment.
So we're trying to
train to be a lion.
We did that last night
up in the Media Lounge.
Any lions from last night here?
We were all--
Geoffrey.
So we were, it's my fourth
lecture, as I told you.
A lovely lecture last night
with the tickling laughter
and the lion experiment.
To lion, is, of course,
pretending to be a lion.
Once you start to
pretend to be a lion,
you realize, oh
I could actually,
I could actually get into that.
I could get very good at it.
And to become a lion,
it is not so easy,
but it's also not impossible.
And you start with a paw.
As you can-- and it takes,
like, we won't do it now.
But you can sort of,
it's called pawing.
The pawing exercise is
already in your mind.
There's a little
space in your brain
that start to evolve, oh,
how do I make a lion paw?
So two cushions,
you're like a lion.
This sort of nice little
four toes on the front.
You can kind of, like, you can
start to the pawing exercise.
And if you go through the
whole thing, you get lion.
And then there's the
famous Sphinx down here.
It's a French, it's a French--
I can talk about it.
The lion experiment comes out
of the French conceptual dancer
who, you might know, had a
lot of success in the '90s,
called Xavier Le Roy.
Is that his name?
Xavier Le Roy?
Amazing French dancer,
conceptual dancer,
who made a lot of
physical experiments,
like one does in dance.
But turning the studio
into a Savannah.
So a very healthy exercise.
See, that's a
classic lion posture.
[LAUGHTER]
Our slow motion trainer.
That guy on that photo.
Now you'll see I'm coming
closer to round this up,
talking about Little Sun.
I wonder, do we
have a Little Sun?
Frederick, do you
Oh, yeah.
Good.
So this is our, I went to
China outside of Shanghai,
in the [INAUDIBLE] gardens.
Amazing rock gardens with
amazing architecture.
And I made a film
about time and space.
And these are the
gardens that went
before the Japanese gardens,
kind of the ancestor
to the Japanese gardens.
And they're lovely here.
It's winter, so
there's no leaves.
Very minimal.
And Steen, who is an old street
dancer, now a slow motion
specialist.
So it was about, so public,
again, next to the street,
and to kind of--
as you know, in China, they
have all these round doors,
and I had these
mirrors in the film.
And the film is 20 minutes long.
So.
It's just that one
shot, or is it--
ah, just see the next scene.
Here Steen is treeing.
See the tree on one side?
I can't.
It's really funny, I think.
But anyway, so this is me
just bringing it to him.
And so I actually do, to get
inspired, I sometimes go out.
This is the park
close to my studio.
And then I'm not as good
at staying in slow motion,
but I go out and I train.
Doing that in public spaces,
like also investigating
the elasticity of
the public space,
does the public
space really like
me making slow motion in it?
You know?
Look at that lovely woman
there, how she looks at me,
and she goes, what
is this guy doing?
You know?
But the question is really
not her looking at me.
The question is more,
how does she feel?
Does she feel comfortable
or uncomfortable?
But just because I'm
walking slow motion,
does she kind of
hold on to her bag?
You know?
So we have to ask ourselves, the
spaces in which we move, what
feelings do they facilitate?
What type of
artistic intervention
would maybe make that explicit,
or challenge that, even?
Is it a problem that
people move differently?
Or maybe it's good.
Maybe diversifying
movements is interesting.
Do you mind me just
skipping that picture?
And this one?
And going to this one.
Because I think I
spoke for a while.
I'll just grab a little.
So a few years from now, a
father from my son's class--
or a guy who has a son in
the same class as my son--
and I were talking, and it turns
out he was a solar engineer.
And knew a lot about light.
And I'm obsessed with
light, and the kind
of ephemeral quality of light.
And, you know, the
sun, as you have seen.
And suddenly we had--
to make a long story short-- we
had this idea of storing light,
storing energy.
And if you could go out into the
sun and kind of take some sun,
just like, do like this,
and then record the sun,
almost like sample.
Like a DJ makes a sample.
And then you take
it somewhere else,
and then you say, OK, this is
the light, I can show you here.
This is how the sun
in Berlin looks like.
This is sunlight from Berlin.
We recorded the light with this
one, the little black thing
here, and I'm playing
it here in Boston.
So it's very interesting.
The light from Berlin traveled,
so the ephemeral quality
of the light from Berlin
traveled with me on the plane
and came to Boston.
And of course, what that means
is that I have a little power
station.
I have access to power in
terms of decentralized power.
I have my own power station.
I am my own power station.
I can choose to have
energy that is mine.
I chart not just
the power station.
I chart myself.
So it's very interesting
with regards to,
do I feel resourceful or not?
Do the space in which I am
allow me to feel resourceful?
What type of space am I?
Maybe the power in
this space I am.
It's highly, let's
say, centralized.
Maybe I have to support
the oil industry.
So maybe the power is
really not the power I want.
Maybe I want this power instead.
If I'm a child who grows up
reading my bedtime stories
with this light,
from six and so on,
maybe I'm more
likely, once I have
to make the choice for energy
in my house when I grow up,
maybe I'm more likely to have
confidence in solar energy
or in alternative
energy resources.
There's so much material in this
which is about so many things.
Frederick Ottesen, the engineer
who's sitting over here,
you should talk to him,
because he's really,
he's really very
MIT, if you want.
The confidence in this
was, to a great extent,
inspired by the collaboration
between engineering
and creativity.
The need, of course, is to raise
the question, the awareness,
the policymaking
about, what does it
mean to have access to energy?
And who have that
responsibility?
And we very quickly came
to the conclusion, well,
this has to work for everybody.
It is not about off grid.
It's about every grid.
Both off and on grid.
Of course, this story about
the climate that I was talking
about, suddenly you
have a little thing here
that makes something
a little bit explicit.
Let's just say it's a foot
in the door in understanding
what on earth is energy.
Right?
So it normally just comes
out of a plug somewhere,
and then you just take it.
And we sometimes
make the mistake,
we take the energy for
granted, as if it was just
like kind of in abundance.
To understand that energy,
you have to go out,
you have to collect it.
And to make, to have a
little power station sort of
teaches you, just
like when, what
do we call this, when we got
the little first steam machine.
Like, how amazing is
that little thing?
Where you're boiling
away your water,
and then suddenly the
wheel turns, and then
you have energy, like,
boiling the water.
So this is the
kind of same thing.
Of course, we then
went specifically
to address the need for
energy in certain groups.
We are looking
now at rural parts
of the world where there is no
energy access, such as Africa.
We have worked for two years.
We're on the ground in
Africa in eight countries.
We're selling them
through a different sort
of private,
market-driven, NGO-driven.
Also with a market component.
It's not an aid project,
and some governments
are totally not successful.
Working with governments
is impossible.
But, you know, the other people.
This is a great success
in terms of where
we are seeing fantastic
sales in the world,
whether it's energy
at a higher price--
$20, $30.
Actually, MoMA in
New York is next week
launching their Spring Catalog
where this is on the cover.
So a lot of lamps and
so on and so forth.
We're selling them
here in Boston.
Also, we have
started selling them
on museums and online and
design stores and so on.
With that profit,
we deliver the lamps
in outlets which also
sell them to build
local economies, micro
economies, and sort
of street vendor economies,
informal economies.
And by doing so, we hope to
create sort of enough profit
at the sort of end of the, what
do you call it, the last mile,
in order for them
to order more lamps.
So it's really not just
about somebody resourceful
and somebody less resourceful.
It's about sort of sharing
a vision of distributing
the resources accordingly.
But the core of this
is a lot of the things
that I spoke about
in the other project.
This is a work of art that
then has wandered outside.
And sometimes, for
a lot of people,
it doesn't necessarily
mean, or doesn't necessarily
have to be a work of art.
But it's never just functional.
It's never just
something functional.
Oh, I need light.
If it doesn't touch
you emotionally,
if you don't feel like you're
holding hands with the sun,
you won't buy it.
You are not going
to convince somebody
to buy a bag, a woman's bag,
[INAUDIBLE] confirm that,
if it's just to carry
your stuff around in it.
Right?
So if that was it,
we wouldn't have
all these incredible companies
now with all these brands
and so on if it was all
about functionality.
This is the same thing.
If it doesn't inspire people.
I saw a young mother
taking her two kids
to school walking
out in the morning,
charging this lamp
around her neck.
And the woman next door says,
oh, my god, look at you,
look at you.
You have to wear this because
you don't have energy.
Oh, you are a victim.
No, the woman who takes
her kids to school and they
who make their homework
with this in the evening,
that woman needs to
say, oh, look at me.
And the woman next door
has to say, oh, amazing.
Why don't I have one of these?
This is cool.
So there's a lot
of stories in this,
but we are trying to address
the language in the same way we
would do here.
That this is about desire,
aspiration, inspiration.
It's about creativity
and self-confidence.
This is, I think, where
engineering and creativity can
work together.
And of course, a great
amount of the success of MIT
has been in its ability to
lean out into other fields.
And I would encourage on
the occasion of today,
and in the spirit
of the McDermott,
I would encourage
this to continue.
To take into your heart the
potential of working together
with, let's just say, the
cultural sector, into the arts,
into the dancers, into
the people who are slow,
into the people who are fast.
Into the writers and theaters
and ballets and music
and so on.
And I think this is
the way to the future.
As I said in the beginning,
the models through which
we are going to create change.
Of course, some
engineering is needed.
I give you that, Frederick.
But touching people
takes something more
than [INAUDIBLE].
Touching people alone
won't do it, also.
So the coming together
between the thinking and the
doing, thinking
being engineering,
and the doing being engineering.
The thinking being
also art and so on.
This is, I think, one of
the solutions in which we
can create a lot of change.
I thank you so much for coming.
Here we have a few questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
That was fabulous.
Thanks [INAUDIBLE].
So you'll take some questions?
Yes, of course.
We have some time for
questions and comments.
And I believe we have
some microphones,
so we'll pass those out.
And anyone want to go first?
Yes, please, if you would.
We need someone on this side,
someone on that-- thanks
so much.
I just saw a hand there.
Hi.
This is really loud.
This might be kind
of a broad question,
but what would your advice be
to a younger artist who aspires
to your level of greatness?
[LAUGHTER]
I think, well, so to my
participant in the school,
I always said it's a
matter of life and death.
If they, within the
question they are asking,
can't sense the urgency, maybe
it's not the right question.
And the urgency can hide
itself in very obscure ways,
but it's really important to,
let's say, to sort of focus
on why before you focus on how.
Because a lot of people
said, oh, how do I this,
how do I that, and so on.
But the question why, and it's
a much more difficult question
to ask.
You know, is this
really necessary?
Why is this necessary?
Especially if you're
an artist where
you seem to be doing a lot
of not so necessary stuff.
You have to, still, find a
little thing, thin string.
Maybe it goes down
to a hand sketch.
Like the little bit of hand
dancing on a piece of paper.
Maybe that's enough why.
I don't mean the rational,
big, justifying why.
Just the kind of
confidence, oh, my god.
I thought something,
now it's on the paper.
It's amazing.
But you have to have the
confidence in the worthwhile.
And that does take some stamina.
As we all know,
it's very difficult
to make a little sort
of doodle on a napkin.
I mean, to make one that
actually sort of matters
is very difficult.
Thank you very much.
This was extraordinary.
I don't know how much
time you have here
in Boston or the area.
But if you haven't,
I would hope you'd
have a chance to visit Artists
for Humanity in South Boston.
Because what you were describing
is this last project, to me,
so encompasses what is
going on today at AFH.
Thank you.
Yes.
It's, I could not agree more.
I'm not, I've been
coming to Boston.
Actually, my first
one person show--
I should have said
that right away--
in America, my first one
person show in America
was at the ICA in Boston.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, with Jill
and Jessie Morgan.
And soon after the first retro--
what do you call it,
it was not exactly
the survey show of my work--
was in San Francisco
that traveled.
And it just, I'll also
say because Madeleine
who did that show,
you mentioned it
at the beginning,
is actually here.
Aren't you, Madeleine?
Oh, there you are.
Hi, Madeleine.
Yes.
Hello.
No, so-- but yeah.
So you're totally right, and no,
I am not here for long enough.
Let's see.
How about all the way
in the back there?
Yes, that, you.
Stacy, you're going to have
to stay up there, I'm afraid.
Thank you.
Was your work in any way
inspired by Christo's work?
I like the idea that
Christo could create
this kind of public attention.
Wrapping the Reichstag
was just around the time
where I was going
to Berlin a lot.
Second week into my art school,
I started in October '89.
End of October, 2 weeks into
art school, the wall in Berlin
came down, and I drove
down, and so on and so on.
And then the Christo, the
Wrapping of the Reichstag
was very important for me.
I was actually more into
the dematerialization team
from the West Coast.
Robert Irwin-- I love Robert
Irwin-- and James Turrell.
The people who somehow
suggested that psychology,
contemplative ideas,
dematerializing art
could be of some importance.
Later, I became more interested
in the East Coast people
like [INAUDIBLE] and the kind
of more sort of structurally
organized people.
Christo kind of came later on.
I was more, like,
Gordon Matta-Clark
or more Robert Morris.
Great.
Oh, hi.
I'm very interested in
the participatory part
of your work, and how
the spectator becomes
a participant, for example,
in the Weather Project.
So I'm wondering,
to what extent do
you plan for a particular
reaction, and to what extent
is it a surprise?
Well, going to art school in
the late '80s, early '90s,
there was very rewarding for me
as a certain regime of object
who'd kind of ended.
The '80s ended.
There were some
focus back on kind
of more political
or activistic ideas.
But a few amazing artists like
Felix Gonzalez-Torres or Cady
Noland came out of America.
Like unbelievably
interesting times.
And for me, it was a moment
where the avant garde
idea of freedom, which
was so important for art,
like that created
modernism, the idea
was somehow suddenly engaging
again with responsibility.
Then we had phenomenology
in the '90s.
We had Deleuze and
people who are thinking
about the sharing, the
co-producing, the co-authoring,
the negotiations, the fact that
reality was, to some extent,
relative.
Bruno Latour came along with
introduced soft sciences
or social sciences, and so.
And I was really
just stepping stones
through all those people.
I sound like, I
sound as though--
I don't, as an artist, you can
just hop through all of that
and enjoy.
Sort of just breathe
the best parts.
But the point here is that
combining this idea of freedom
and the responsibility
that comes with that.
And then the idea of
responsibility, very much,
is about-- freedom is
always about me, me, me, me.
I want to be free.
And there's a degree
of, at some point,
you can be so avant garde
that you kind of disconnect.
You become so much
about your own,
the conditions of your own,
the freedom of speech, almost.
So I think my generation, and
I'm lucky to be a part of that
generation, this sense of
responsibility introduced
the notion, well you cannot be
responsible if you're only one
person.
Like with freedom.
You have to be at least two
people, and better even more.
This is where the door is
sort open to the kind of idea
of the participatory
productivity,
I would almost call it.
Considering the visitor to
the museum being almost as
important as the artist.
Being an artist, I would
just sort of, just keep it.
But, and of course,
and the truth is museum
thinks that they are
the most important.
So they kind of miss,
they miss the whole thing.
But the point--
[LAUGHTER]
But by all means, if
there would be no artists,
there would be no museums.
Let's just sort of make that.
But then you have the visitors.
Probably, also, there
would be without visitors,
there would no-- so I think
the participatory also
have to do with showing
that trust in people being
able to use abstraction
for something valuable
is so important.
And it just doesn't happen.
If you look at the ways
that, how should I say?
Everybody said, look
at the internet.
Now I had this amazing meeting
with all these so talented
people up at the Media Lab.
Several groups.
And so I said now, I'm very
uncertain whether what I say
is now actually true.
But, you know, the tendency
is, of course, people,
they kind of just consume.
They don't produce.
And I've learned today this
is maybe not totally true.
But generally speaking, I'm
very interested in handing over
the trust to the people
that they feel that they
can actually produce realities.
So I just like a
reality machine.
But if you don't participate
in it, it doesn't do anything.
Right there, if you could
just pass the microphone.
Thank you.
Hi.
As a light artist, do you
feel a sense of responsibility
in promoting solar power
and energy efficiency
in your installations?
Like as a sort of role model for
people and artists to follow?
Or do you choose
that in your work?
Yeah, to some extent.
I have, yeah, I'm
not, maybe, the kind
of typical ecologically
very correct artist.
I'm also not the worst.
You know, I think, to be
honest, I have to a great extent
become involved with
being, like you suggest,
that, well, I better,
I better start
using LED bulbs in a sculpture.
Is somehow, somehow
it's also important.
But I also have to
say that looking at,
what do you call it?
Condensendant lamp is
not the right word.
[AUDIENCE MURMURS]
(MUMBLING) Incandescent.
So then if you
look at that, it's
just so much more beautiful
than a bloody LED.
So what do you do if you
want to address beauty?
But then again, these
lovely LED companies,
they keep sending me
small samples and say--
and the quality of the light
actually does get better.
A lot better, actually.
And now, you know, we
have great LED panels
who are very, very interesting.
But it's important to
understand it's just,
it's maybe in an
evolution, it is not
replacing something else.
It's maybe something
which is just ending,
and then something
else is taking over.
So in that sense, yes.
I have started becoming
much more aware of it.
It took me some time.
It did take me some time.
This is an LED.
And it's interesting.
Not a long time ago, that
was an expensive LED.
Now it's like, this
is a quality LED.
And now it's, how
much is it, Frederick?
0.06 cents.
And it's a good LED.
It's from-- now every
time I say this--
I won't say.
But it's-- we bought it,
so I don't have to say it.
But this is the price of an LED.
I remember in seventh--
no, I started school, '70s.
There was this amazing
girl in the seventh grade.
I was like, I was first grade.
And she had this,
I thought I should
have said it at the beginning.
She had this incredible,
so I was very curious.
She had this amazing
calculator in her bag.
And I was not exactly
in love with it,
but I thought she was amazing.
And then I looked at it, and
then it had all these other,
it was brown and gold
and they had red digits.
I just looked at that red color.
And it's so funny because
it was a Texas Instrument.
And I was so excited to see
there was the numbers 1 to 9
and then plus minus,
and then there
was all the other things
one could press on.
I was like, by god.
And the red color of that light.
So I was, at the
beginning, I remember
from very early on being
taken about the quality
of an experience of light
and this incredible girl.
And, you know, the
engineering effort.
And it's actually the
first time I came across,
and I remember very clearly
the Texas Instrument.
Do you remember they were
kind of gold and brown?
It's kind of funny.
Right here.
Thank you.
All right.
How collaborative
is your studio?
Say that again?
How collaborative
is your studio?
It's, I rely a lot on
the talent at the studio.
There's a lot of things that--
I've done it all.
And then at some
point in the process,
I say, oh, too much logistics.
I want to only do
the creative stuff.
Then you ask somebody
to do it, then it
turns out they do it
much better than--
or a little bit
better-- than I did.
And it just so turns
out that, actually, it's
become a much better run place
after other people assisted
and took over.
And so on.
And now, of course,
where's the [INAUDIBLE]??
I would like to think that
I'm the artist and the one who
makes the call.
And this means that I start
an idea, I start a process.
Very often it's fed by
an already existing,
but I start something.
Then we go, we branch
into five options,
and we work on five
options, digitally models,
build it, make it testing,
testing with water,
underwater with
light or something.
And then say, oh, the three
options, they are impossible.
I don't like them.
Why don't we take
these two options?
Then everybody works
on these two options,
and then we build a model
of the space one to one.
We take the space from them,
literally moves it to Berlin,
then we build it up.
And then there's
two teams, almost.
And then I'm involved.
Then we bring in theory.
Criticizing, did somebody
do something similar?
What were they thinking?
So 200 years ago, there
was kind of a symphony
about that particular problem.
Should we listen to
that while we do it?
So then a lot of ideas
are coming together.
So it's a little bit
difficult to say where is
the exact sort of boundaries.
But we are, I hope we all
agree that I'm the one who
makes those sort of final call.
[LAUGHTER]
But I have on the other
side, I've always, always
had an open door policy.
Because there is
a lot of artists--
and bless them for that--
who have closed and mystified
the artist studio.
And kept, in order to
prevent-- and I would argue,
for market reasons--
the kind of, this idea
of sort of keeping secret
that there is like a painter
who only makes painting and has,
like, 90 assistants painting.
[INAUDIBLE] kind of like, sort
of obvious he has to keep it
closed.
Because it would sort of
not so good for his market,
you could say.
I don't think of
that being a problem.
I think, why don't
everybody just come and look
for themselves?
And I don't mean that literally.
But the principle
is, that's why I've
done a number of
works addressing
the studio as laboratory,
as a sort of producer.
I worked with the idea
of mixing the museum,
the studio, the residency.
The school was in
my studio exactly
to kind of show the students,
well, let's just be pragmatic.
Let's be MIT-ish about it, and
sort of think of it as a lab.
Obviously one would think that
there is a degree of leadership
at MIT as well, sort
of pushing the things
in the right direction.
And I think of my
studio like that.
And I have no problem
suggesting that art
can, to a great extent, be a
collaborative effort like that.
Please, yes.
Can you talk a little
bit about the nature
of viewers' engagement
with your work
after the project is completed?
Like the Weather Project looks
so fantastic, but none of us
will ever see it.
And so there's a
real dilemma there
where on-site, it
seems very immersive
and emotional and interactive,
but then we only experience it
10 years later as a
kind of discourse.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So for me, it doesn't
really ever end.
And it's not like the work
before was somehow less
important than the actual work.
And now with the Weather
Project, it did end,
and it did close.
I remember, they
wanted to prolong it.
We did one time prolong it.
Then they were so
successful they said,
why don't we run it
for another six weeks?
And then I said,
no, let's close it.
It's like so successful.
Why not close it now?
But it did continue.
It turned out, I
was with a professor
today at the Media Lab.
What was his name, Lillah?
Which one?
I'm sorry.
The guy who had the photo of
the Weather Project on his book?
Oh!
William Uricchio.
What?
William Uricchio from CMS.
William Uricchio CMS.
So he had a book with--
so it's sort of still around.
Do you know what I mean?
The Weather Project was
on the cover of his book.
And he still had--
so funny-- he actually
had to ask for permission,
but it's an old book.
And in a way, these
projects, I look at them
more as kind of
cause and effect.
So you do something that
sets some motion into action.
And eventually, something dies
out and something still moves.
So the project isn't
really over in that sense.
It was not about the actual
shape of the project.
It was about the, well,
I shouldn't say science.
But it was about the kind of
material that it negotiated.
And that material
is still around.
The work is still
producing reality.
In this case, it's
a sort of dialogue.
It's hopefully being
considered as a work that
is worth bringing up in
different discussions.
I have-- yeah.
Maybe this gentleman
there in the center.
He's had his hand up.
If you could just--
thank you.
I saw the Weather Project
in London and was impressed.
But I may be the
only other person
here with solar, so here's
some light from Cambridge
from yesterday.
Great.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's about 10 years
old off the shelf equipment
that I've been using for my bike
lights every day since then.
And it's amazing to me that
I'm the only person that I
see walking around MIT
with something like that,
or Cambridge, or Boston.
The very few people
who take care of that.
In the Little Sun one of the
things that I find about solar
is that it's currency.
And local production, in
terms of Gandhian economics.
Swadeshi local production.
But light is one currency.
Electricity, which is
what runs the light,
also can run AA
batteries, which are
the most used batteries in the
world, and charge cell phones.
And there's seven
billion cell phones
now in the world for seven
and a half billion people.
And I'm wondering if you're
extending your idea from light
to the currency of
electricity and the economics
of the solar Swadeshi.
Yes, it's a good question.
And the thing is, I've been
stepping through a departments
here, and I've been
meeting definitely
20 people who are
working with solar,
and small solar objects in the
micro solar systems and so on.
So if you ask me, there's,
like, solar everywhere.
But, yes, I know Frederick tells
me not to be talking about it.
But we are, this summer,
actually bringing
out the Little Sun
mobile charger.
Sort of a very
beautiful, exactly
because of the same thing.
We are working very hard on
our retail and business model
and delivery systems and
the whole economic sort
of so-called BOP economic.
And we had [INAUDIBLE] input,
also, on some ideas on that.
So I didn't say that before.
You should really not hesitate
to go to littlesun.com.
And there's a few introductions.
Some are more
technical, if you're
more in the kind of
nerdy area, and some
are more emotional if you're
more sort of creative.
But what I'm actually asking
you is not quite going to do it.
You have to, then,
there's all that like it,
send it into Instagram, and
all that social media stuff,
which we live off.
So this is how people actually
learn about this story
and bring about.
And we have brought, and I
didn't bring that number.
We have produced 250,000 lamps.
One, about 180 we have
already delivered.
30%, one third, has been
delivered in off grid.
So it's a great equation.
This means we have in the
two-- one and a half year,
almost two years--
we have actually
had a robust curve.
This is why I have to
tell you, you need to,
it's not enough for
me to talk about it.
You need to go and then
say, send it a friend,
oh, let's send it to
a friend and like it
and Facebook and all of that.
Simply, this is what
has been driving us.
So the online communities,
the sharing the stories,
the uploading
images, has been one
of the drivers in the
success, which we also
talked about here at MIT,
because there's so much talent
in that field as well.
So it's very interesting.
It's not just
engineering and art.
It's also communication, retail
policy making, new economies,
economical model,
micro distribution,
last mile successes, and so on.
I have rarely, it's like
being a young artist again.
I have learned so much
from this project.
I have also learned
to be humble.
That's very new for me.
[LAUGHTER]
I think we have
time for one more.
Yes, please.
I mean this in the
broadest sense possible.
But to you, what is
the place of spectacle
when you're making art?
I'm sorry, say that again?
For you, what is the
place of spectacle
when you're making art
or thinking about art?
So I work a lot with the sort
of experiential potential.
And of course, I would want
people to take a groundbreaking
experience, and that
could be a sort of micro,
or should I say nano
groundbreaking experience.
Or a really groundbreaking,
the big sort
of pathetic groundbreaking
type of experience.
But I'm also quite
aware of, there
is economy, which is very
active within the notion
of the spectacle.
And that economy has brought
about the experience industry,
or experience economy.
And of course, the kind
of shallow or hollowness
of the spectacle with
regards to facilitating
a profitable idea of how to
drive the experience economy.
So I'm sometimes,
frankly speaking,
torn between how can I
suggest that what I do
is not just hollow?
But how do you, in the world
today, it's also hard to see.
And look at something
and go, like, well,
does this person
actually really mean it?
Or is it just some
kind of la la la?
And it's difficult, and
it's getting difficult,
especially as the museums
and the institutions that
facilitate, they are
forced in our society
into systems where
they need to quantify
their successes by virtue of
telling the politicians so
on so many numbers, so on
so much success criteria
that you can actually measure
is how we run the museum.
And of course, then the
artists, you go like, huh?
What about if my
show was not sort
of a high hitter in numbers?
Does that mean it
wasn't good art?
So of course, we are
seeing situations
where the spectacle
is kind of becoming
an ambiguous situation, where
a museum is kind of forced
into a situation,
where if we are going
to keep up the funding, we have
to deliver something like that.
And then they call me.
Right?
And then I have to--
[LAUGHTER]
--then I have to
have that bit of sort
of a kind of dancing with
the museum about, well,
instead of talking about how,
we should talk about why.
And that takes a
little time, sometimes.
Because once you're into
the discussion of why,
normally you can nail the
museum down to the values
that they used
when they started.
And this is, I think,
where it gets interesting.
And then you can bring museums
into the sort of risk zone.
And then you obviously
need to not just call
the fire department and say,
oh, it's going to be OK.
Just let's do it.
It's going to be OK.
You also call the
politician and say,
why don't we take that risk?
By god, for god's sake,
it's about art, anyway.
It's not about
politicians and so on.
And sadly, this is getting
increasingly difficult to say.
Museums being so forced into
the traditional commerce,
the commodification
of our sense,
of the experience
economy, blah blah blah.
So there is a very
important area there.
And we also have
to say in America,
the private sector is the one
that is supporting the museums.
We need the private sector
to be very risk oriented.
And as we know,
the private sector
is not necessarily the
most risk oriented.
[INAUDIBLE] by all
means, the public sector
is not risk oriented as well.
So it's a very
interesting discussion.
How do we facilitate a space
in which an experience can
be about the experience and
not about all that other stuff?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
Just a word.
The Council for the Arts at
MIT has demonstrated, again,
impeccable taste in
selecting Olafur.
And I've got to say, if
Frederick Ottesen is very MIT,
so are you.
Yeah.
Delighted you're here.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.